en plein village une bâtisse fortement
protégée c'est ici que les 64 membres de
la communauté du grand logis attendait
souhaite la marque alice événements qui
ne menacerait aucunement leur existence
cette apocalypse pour nous c'est un
message de vie c'est un message d'espoir
nous nous préparons pour cela nous c'est
un inverse totalement de tout ce que
nous pouvons croire la notion de suicide
croyances et selon bernard brio les
habitants du grand logis ne comprennent
pas ce qui s'est produit dans la secte
de l'ordre du temple solaire
elle est complètement horrifié que des
êtres attendre l'apocalypse ne rien
faire vous la provoquer c'est la
doctrine grand logis reste les
accusations portées par ce qu'ils ont
quittée séquestration endoctrinement
discipline intérieure délirante aucune
réponse à ces questions le groupe
préfère mettre en avant les bons
rapports qu'il entretient avec le
villaret ya aucun problème
puis on va pourquoi je dirais autre
chose à lavilledieu personne ne se
plaint des membres du grand logis même
s'il apparaît évident que les femmes
sont cloîtrés à l'intérieur des murs
affaire privée nous dira-t-on
seul le sort des enfants sont de
susciter des interrogations entre après
tout ils sont libres de croire et de
penser je prends ça existe bon et normal
que je dirais qu'on peut comprendre mais
c'est vrai que ça nous étonne de voir
que nous n'avons pas en place mais dont
on sait qu'ils ont le droit de les
éduquer les enfants sur place quoi ils
sont dix sept enfants dont le plus jeune
a 6 ans instruit par une ancienne
institutrice membres du grand logis des
enfants en bonne santé mais qu'on élève
dans l'attenté imminente de la fin d'un
monde dont ils ne connaissent rien parce
que eux n'ont pas choisi de vivre un
flou